So now we'll take a look and see if our
changes got propagated to the API's Explorer. You may find that
you need to refresh the API's Explorer to get the latest
changes. So you drill down to the conference API and again
with the safe profile, look at the safe profile and
here you'll see now, here you'll see now, that we have
the request body property showing up or the request property field
showing up. If you click in it, and this is really
cool, you'll see the add a property menu. You
go ahead and click that to bring the menu up,
and it'll show you the properties that you're allowed to
add. So we're going to add a display name. Let's say
we'll se it to Lauren. Now we're going to go
ahead and add another property, we'll add a T-shirt size.
Set that to M for medium and we execute it
and you see the request that got sent? The display
name was Lauren, T-shirt size M and we also
see the response. Which is the profile that got
created. The display name is Lauren, T-shirt size is
M. So these are the same fields that are defined
in the profile form class. Which is the input
of the parameter to the save profile method. So hopefully
you've learned how you can restrict the input to
the, API by passing the argument in the API function.
Now it's your turn to update the save
profile function in conference API to take the profile
form param as an input argument. You'll be implementing
the code marked with TODO1, look for the one.
The method has a couple different places where
you'll need to be adding code, but this time
we're just doing the places marked TODO1. Go ahead
and add the profile form argument to the save
profile method in the conference API class. And
go ahead and do the other sections marked
TODO1 to get the arguments out of the
profile form argument that gets passed in. When
you've made your changes, run your app on
localhost and visit it in API's Explorer, and
then go ahead and explore. See what happens
when you execute the save conference function. Try executing
it with and without providing the display
name and the T-shirt size parameters. When
you've tested it out on localhost and it's working like you think it should,
go ahead and deploy your app to app spot. And when you're ready you
can enter your app ID here and press submit so Udacity can test your code.